how is it that some of the criteria for
promotion to military organizations are
evidently such as to favor people with a
pathological degree of achievement
motivation this is scary
the person that might have a tendency to
get promoted is the one that's looking
out for themselves
in some cases in the military again it's
important to say this isn't like the
entire military
but certainly i certainly saw people in
the military that were 100 looking out
for themselves and they got promoted
yeah that does happen there's no doubt
about it it happens less than you would
think
a lot of times that transparency that
these idiots would have looking out for
themselves and trying to make those
maneuvers everyone would see it and
they'd be like no you're not getting
promoted
but it did happen
there are grounds for thinking that
incompetent commanders tend to be those
whom the need to avoid failure exceeds
the urge to succeed
according to jw atkinson and nt feather
such people tend to issue activities
which they may show up in a poor light
and unless forced to do so refrain from
taking on any skilled task where there
are any doubts about the outcome so
people
that are just concerned about themselves
they'll only go into jobs where they
know they're going to win
that's what they're trying to do they're
just they're they're only doing jobs of
things that they know they're going to
do they know that they're going to win
at
hearing lies a special dilemma though
they need to achieve
it is the very nature of trying which
exposes them to that which they fear
most failure
they are like people who try to climb
mountains
out of an underlying fear of heights
it would not be surprising to find that
such people are attracted to and prosper
in the armed services for if one plays
it carefully in the military in contrast
to the world of commerce offers
achievement without tears stick to the
rule book do nothing wild explicit
approval from the next higher up always
confirm form never offend your superiors
and you will float serenely if a trifle
slowly upward a blimp in both senses of
the word
that's the reality you can't you there
you can do that
you can join the military and you can
just kind of keep your nose clean stay
low profile don't take any additional
risks
conform and you will get promoted over
time in many cases marine corps is
tighter though i think
i'd like to think that i mean you're
described what you're describing i can
i'm
he's right yeah and i've seen it and not
not right in a blanket statement no no
no but it certainly happens yes yeah no
correct and and you're right in saying
like that's part of the system is is you
have you might show for this altruism of
how it works and the wrong people get
promoted sometimes now it's not a lot of
those people it's actually a small
number like you said
but it happens enough that you will see
it you're not going to go a career and
go oh i never saw that every single time
it was the right person of the right
reasons no throughout my career there
was examples that i can reflect back on
it's a small number but the system
doesn't work perfectly
and i think the thing i was thinking
about and this is military i think in
general there are enough jobs in the
military
that have been done enough times that
the template is there that you go i can
take those head orders and like man
it's really low risk you know i'm going
to be cutter the cookie cutter job
that's been done and take the template
jacko's gonna head off to me here's the
you know here's the script follow the
script low profile
um low risk you're gonna look good in
the end and you're gonna get promoted
there there are those jobs out there
i was lucky in my career
to have jobs that either had never been
done before or really there wasn't a lot
of history behind them so
you know i'm remembering a couple times
like when i was in command of an
organization
where
you know i was being told hey um
if this fails it's going to destroy the
whole thing like oh that's uh okay okay
that's awesome i think i've told the
story before i'm far enough away from it
now that i can i can tell it if i
haven't before but when i took over the
first f-35 squadron uh the marine corps
f-35 program was on probation
like they were contemplating canceling
the f-35 for the marine corps the b
variant which was the marine corps
variant and the marine corps already
long since committed to that was the
only platform there was no plan b there
was no alternative to that so if we were
going to lose the f-35b the marine corps
was going to lose tac air
and um as soon as i took command and you
know i stood up i told you there's a guy
there before no airplanes but when i
took command the airplane started to
arrive right when i got there the
comrade of the marine corps came down
um
spent like an hour with me they met him
at the squadron was he and his target
major and me and my sergeant major and
he goes hey i hate to tell you this
but you can't crash an airplane oh like
wow that's
oh
roger that roger that you know what i
mean like if you crash an airplane we're
gonna lose the program marino's gonna
lose that care
and so you're talking about the the
balance of the risk of losing is a lot
you know the balance that between the
benefit of winning well just you know
marginal benefit of winning but like
there's zero risk or you know the flip
side is hey if i go two years as a
squadron commander everything goes great
i'm going to get a firm handshake and a
congratulations and light's going to go
on but nobody's going to credit me for
doing anything remarkable because the
system is the the program is just moving
along where it needs to go but if i
screwed up
you know that downside risk and and i
understand the
the aversion to that like hey would you
rather have a guaranteed win with you
know a guaranteed marginal win with no
chance of losing
or
high
risk of failure
but this is a once in a lifetime thing
that would need the right person the
right time to go through that a lot of
people are reversed to that yep well and
this is the other scary thing about that
is
so you're the squadron commander you get
told don't crash any birds
well
how about we fly a little less yes right
interesting said that because in the
exact same weekend
the
deputy commandant for aviation the head
aviator the marine corps
said your number one job is to fly as
much as humanly possible damn roger that
okay
and listen there's a part of it too that
you have to understand this like
there is nothing that i could do
personally short of shutting down the
squadron right to guarantee they don't
care there's nothing i can do that
so
there's a part of that like if you can
just let that go just recognize my best
chance of me being successful is to
micromanage none of this yeah as opposed
to trying to macromanage all of it yep
you know and that's such a good point
because
okay we can either fly as little as
humanly possible which means everyone's
paranoid no one really knows how to do
their job very like all right we're
gonna fly these things we'd be awesome
at it and that's the right call
obviously not everyone would make that
decision and even then they're still
even the right call doesn't guarantee
the outcome you can do everything right
and you know what yeah you have a mishap
on me those air traps yes things break
yeah things breaking mid-flight yep that
happens they do especially brand new
airplanes they're still being designed
while you're flying them those things
happen
how many f-35s have crashed
not a lot so
i believe i have to go back and look i
think the first one crashed in my
squadron like six months after i left
um yeah got out of it
um
we've there's been a very small it's
been a very safe airplane what does an
f35 cost
at the time it was 130 million now it's
probably 90.
oh so they cut the price down a little
bit well those first ones are like you
know they were literally the very first
ones off the assembly line so that that
as you know like that mass production
benefit hadn't kicked in yet so h1 was
kind of like a unique article now like
they're jamming them out they're making
a bunch of them and it's it's more cost
effective i know these are crazy numbers
but at the time they were they were
expensive
133 a copy i had 14. if you
when you fly an f-35 and you're doing a
vertical how how often did you do a
vertical takeoff
uh
like a short take off like the stovall
like the yeah like yeah like a hairier
yeah
not that often sometimes it's how much
gas do you go through taking one of
those things off vertically
the vertical flying burns a ridiculous
amount of gas you just basically have to
refuel as soon as you get up it's not
that bad but it's it's a lot of gas yeah
the the landings are more of a critical
because you're on the clock like you
come in you got to be relatively light
you can't land like a fully loaded
airplane vertically because it's too
heavy okay so you got to be like a
certain limited amount of gas so the
plane is light enough to hover
but then again like you can't just you
know sit there all day long because you
don't have that much gas it's nothing
like the harrier was those guys it was
sketchy like really really sketchy but
um yeah you're burning a lot of gas a
lot it was sketchy in a hairier what
made it more sketchy um less powerful
airplane harder to fly less margin for
air less you needed less gas to be able
to land and didn't have as much time you
know just
i figured i flew the uh harrier
simulator out at yuma yeah dude i
crashed that thing literally 17 times in
a row my total flight time was nine
seconds just hope that i just crashed if
you got into an f35 right now in the
simulator i could over the shoulder walk
you through it you landed
almost perfectly the first try
well that's like drones
man those first drones came out that
were like little model airplanes guys
were just crashing everywhere and now
a three-year-old can fly a drone and
that's that's no exaggeration yeah